Of the six Infinity Stones, the Soul Stone
is arguably the trickiest to wrap your head
around.
Of particular concern is the question of what
happens to the stone if it's returned to the
place from which it was taken.
Thankfully, the writers of Avengers: Endgame
have come forward to explain exactly what
happened to the Soul Stone in the film.
First, a little refresher.
Avengers: Endgame sees Black Widow and Hawkeye
take a trip to the mysterious planet of Vormir
on a mission to pluck the Soul Stone out of
time before Thanos or his minions can acquire
it.
Hawkeye ultimately obtains the Stone after
Black Widow heroically throws herself off
the planet's massive cliff, echoing the same
sequence from Infinity War in which Thanos
killed Gamora for the stone.
Before he retires to a life of slow dancing
with Peggy Carter at the end of the movie,
Captain America travels back to the past to
place the Stone in the same spot it was in
before Black Widow sacrificed herself.
As MCU fans now know, there are pretty specific
rules for what has to happen before someone
can take the Soul Stone from Vormir.
"In order to take the stone, you must lose
that which you love.
A soul...for a soul."
After Infinity War and Endgame, we've seen
that part of the process go down twice.
But we've never before seen anyone try to
put that Soul Stone back.
How did Cap successfully return the Soul Stone?
And, perhaps more importantly, would putting
the Soul Stone back revive the person who
died for it?
Christopher Markus and Stephen McFeely explained
during a recent episode of CinemaBlend's HeroBlend
podcast that Captain America faced no trouble
returning the Soul Stone, but sadly, the soul-for-a-soul
exchange that Black Widow and Hawkeye made
with the keeper of the Stone, Red Skull, wasn't
reversed in that moment.
"How does one return the Soul Stone?"
"It's a good question.
I think it is an everlasting exchange."
"There's a slot."
"That's right.
That's right, it's like an old-time bank."
Unfortunately, this shows that just because
the Soul Stone was returned doesn't mean that
those who were sacrificed to retrieve it get
to come back to life.
The exchange is permanent, and the soul that
was sacrificed can't be retrieved.
As Markus put it,
While fans held onto the hope that Black Widow
could perhaps be resurrected once Captain
America put the Soul Stone back on Vormir,
that's apparently not going to happen, as
it's simply not the way the Soul Stone works.
Cap returning the Soul Stone only patched
up the timeline, it didn't undo Black Widow's
death.
This has a huge repercussion on the future
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe, since Marvel
Studios is currently developing a Black Widow
solo movie.
How that's going to work with a dead Black
Widow is sort of up in the air.
It's possible the movie will be a prequel,
giving us the backstory for Black Widow that
the other MCU movies have only ever teased
at.
It's also possible that she really is alive
out there somewhere, brought back by Hulk's
use of the Infinity Stones without him or
anyone else knowing about it.
It's also possible that the movie will focus
on an entirely different Black Widow; at this
point, we just don't know.
While Marvel has kept quiet about the film,
there have been some clues as to when Black
Widow's solo adventure might be set.
Past reports pin the film as being a period
piece, set partially in Natasha Romanoff's
younger years working with the KGB, and then
jumping forward to 15 years after the fall
of the KGB.
If Markus and McFeely are to be believed,
and there truly is no way that Nat can be
resurrected, then there isn't any other point
in time that Black Widow screenwriter Jac
Schaeffer can place the film other than years
before the events of Avengers: Endgame.
Losing Black Widow in Avengers: Endgame was
a painful experience.
And though she may never come back to life
in the present day to join the Avengers who
lived through the film, it looks like super-spy
is all set to make at least one more appearance
on the big screen before fans say goodbye.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.